There are different strategies and
methodologies of doing dawa. Some are
less effective while the others are more
effective. The most common method or
most common strategy used by the common
Muslim is for doing dawa to non-Muslim
is that when they meet a non-Muslim,
they speak 100 good things about Islam.
Even if that non-Muslim agrees with
those 100 points that are good in Islam,
yet at the back of his mind, he will
think, "Ah, you are the same Muslim
who's a terrorist. Ah, you're the same
Muslim who's a fundamentalist. Ah,
you're the same Muslim who is an
extremist.
Ah, you are the people who spread your
religion with the sword. Ah, you are the
people who marry more than one woman.
You are the people who subjugate the
woman by keeping her behind the veil.
These few negative mis negative points
of Islam or negative misconceptions or
allegations against Islam prevents the
non-Muslim from accepting the beauty of
Islam. So what do I do whenever I meet
any non-Muslim? I ask him upfront, what
do you feel is wrong with Islam? with
your limited knowledge whether right or
wrong what do you feel is wrong with
Islam and I make him comfortable you can
criticize Islam you can attack Islam I'm
young I can take it don't go on my white
beard I can take it I make him
comfortable that you can criticize Islam
you can attack Islam and after I make
him comfortable he poses about three or
four questions regarding Islam and these
three or four question that he poses
invariably falls amongst the 20 most
common questions asked by the
non-Muslim. The 20 most common questions
about Islam asked by the non-Muslims.
I've been in the field of dawa for more
than 30 years. And I've realized that
whenever I travel in different parts of
the world, these 20 common questions are
the same.
So my request to my Muslim brothers and
sisters is that you should know the
answers of these 20 most common
questions asked about Islam by the
non-Muslims and normally when you give a
answer the answer should be holistic
and I prefer that the answer should
contains quotation from the Quran the
say Hadi to tell the non-Muslim what is
Islamic point of view though he may not
agree we can quote the scriptures of the
non-Muslim Whether it be the Bible,
whether it be the Vedas, the Upanishads,
the Bhagat Gita, so that we can prove
from their scriptures the Islamic point
of view. The answer should contain
reason and logic. The answer should
contain scientific evidence so that the
answer is holistic. And it is preferable
much better to memorize the answer to
the 20 most common questions about Islam
asked by the non-Muslims than to
memorize 200 uncommon questions.
And if you memorize these, if you
memorize the answers to these 20 most
common questions asked by non-Muslims
about Islam, even if you cannot convert
them, at least you can remove the
animosity which is there in their mind
regarding Islam. You can remove the
misconceptions
about Islam which is there in the minds
of the non-Muslim. And I've written a
book on this topic. It's available on
the internet if you Google.
drzakin.com
or zakin.com you can go to the website
the there are many books available even
this with the title of
answers to the 20 most common questions
asked by non-Muslims
how do these 20 common questions arise
in the mind of the non-Muslims depending
on how the media portrays Islam
these 20 common questions keep on
changing today we find in the in the
international media, whether it it be
the international newspapers, the
international magazines, the
international radio broadcast station,
the international satellite channels,
whether it be the social media, we find
there is virulent propaganda regarding
Islam. We find that the international
media is bombarding misconceptions
regarding Islam. And depending on how
the media portrays Islam, these 20 most
common questions keep on changing.